hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now we
are prepared where we're not prepared
but I mean we have things and stuff I
don't know I I don't want to make it in
bold claim [ __ ] undoing so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to start off
with something that I have not been able
to start off on in a long time which is
reading comments and putting them on
lockers like I'm supposed to be doing I
would make more lockers but I'm trying
to ration out what I have so for now we
have Kody wishing over here on the right
who said mark never take any risks don't
lose the prom suit don't engage the
warper and definitely never go out
without food water and health though I
think you may capture the warper with
the alien containment chamber to keep it
away from you assuming there's only one
basically Kody Wishon is my parents and
trying to make me play it safe does this
look like the face of someone that plays
it safe now absolutely [ __ ] not I
don't play anything safe anyway then
there's shame to 6/5 it says the ghost
Leviathan will be roaming the Walsh
River and there are two sea dragons one
in the lava zone and one in the lava
castle why are there two can I kill them
somehow can I punch them to death like I
did that crab squid that'd be nice
that's interesting about the ghost
Leviathan like how many license do they
need to make in this game
how many Leviathan species are there and
then there's destructive corpse mm will
marks a bumble but will the warper
finally confess his love for mark tune
in next time on another episode of
subnautica thank you very much
and yeah I didn't save him yeah the
warper does love me I think but I think
I already knew that it was an unspoken
love
Hey without convenient timing for the
salt I don't need it right now I need
the water please
so these are still cranking out water
but they're not ready yet I made another
one I don't know if I showed that but
it'll be ready soon a little bit they're
very slow God they need a lot of power
but then again I need a lot of water so
hopefully that'll get done in relatively
quick timing
I bet anyway I got some other stuff for
decoration in case you guys were curious
about it I have a coffee vending machine
does me I know I'm dehydrated I'm well
aware of that but I've just got random
knickknacks to put around my place so
that's the thing that I'm currently
worried about so anyway all that aside
there are other things that I want to do
I want to be able to get the grappling
hook for my prawn suit to be able to go
around quicker and be able to maneuver
quicker but the only problem is I need
some more materials that I didn't get
the last time yeah I got titanium and
nothing else
hahahaha so I'm going to go out and farm
real quick because I need some gold and
silver and eventually eventually
eventually eventually a long way down
the road probably in the next episode
I'm going to need to build a cyclops and
to be able to do that I need a lot of
[ __ ] and I don't have a lot of [ __ ] I've
got a lot of not [ __ ] I don't even want
to get the enamel glass but I got to do
that so that's going to be on the road
and I'm going to do that because that is
also going to be help me explore deeper
down and be an active lava zone
let me do my farming first and then I'm
going to take this one step at a time
because that's the whole point of coming
back to this is like I didn't want to
rush through anything I didn't want to
rush through what we had here I wanted
to explore everything a little bit of
time and that meant taking my time with
the whole game so another thing to note
I have this orange artifact and I have
no idea what it is I have no idea what
it does I have no idea what it's for but
all I know is that I have it what good
it'll do me I'm not 100% sure but I
don't think I should keep it on my
person because I think I'm going to need
that down in the inactive lava zone
another alien base to explore and I'll
get to that very soon but right now I've
got work to do and I need some [ __ ]
water gimme some water geez just right
oh I'm gonna go get some stuff I'll be
back you'd be good care and take care of
the place for me cared ha ha ha little
jokes to remind us how much we hate each
other anyway off I go
I need table coral and gold and silver
and probably quartz and other things
thankfully I don't think I need to go
nearly as far I can just come here over
here and get these out crossing whatever
they have it's probably what I'm gonna
need a copper lad
silver that's what I mean not that elder
Oh
not what I need at table cool what's
that still alive and pulsating not for
long sorry sorry boy boy boy sorry I
don't think I need more than that do it
yeah probably not
silver new computer chips man swapping
kits I know I need two of those alright
now that I got those I should be good
for now if I remember correctly but I
don't know if I do yeah that's all I
need I need advanced wiring kits and
titanium and then I'll have a grappling
arm which he'll be supercool I won't
have my punching ability which is
something that I really love I sure do
love to be able to punch [ __ ] but
you know it's for the best
maybe my reckless punching was
destroying the ecosystem further than I
already was I saw that movement sancho
that looked like Leviathan movement to
me you're an [ __ ] for trying to
impersonate a [ __ ] Leviathan what are
you doing sideways you having a good old
giggle
Oh giggly over there are you having a
giggle mate uh how about you go heat is
eat it eat it eat eat it eat it eat it
eat something you look hungry down we
going to the Depp zombie close into the
engine finger he dips fingers weird it's
just like I understand that that nature
is weird and this is an artificial game
but it's just bizarre because you look
at this up you're like wow this can't be
natural it's just so weird and alien but
then again you think about like
topographical stuff here on earth and
it's [ __ ] bizarre and honestly who
knows at the bottom of the ocean there's
there's like incredibly amazingly unseen
things lurking in our own ocean it's
ridiculous how much we don't know about
our own ocean and yet we just live with
it every day because honestly who wants
to volunteer to go down there not I not
this guy no way okay back home sweet
home talking about life shut shut your
face well got your face I've got to make
a change
first off I've got it gonna make me a
prawn grappling arm then I gotta get my
prawn back in there Dougal dangle means
I got a hook to let me hop these hop D
hoop you going through the bottom and
then back through the top of an [ __ ]
right so let me just get the lights on
this place that looks good so now let me
do another maneuver thanks you
ease in there goodies on in there Oh
docking sequence will he'll go nailed it
the whole time knew what I was doing I
got it right so then I just got a no
that's not right gotta go in here to be
upgrade menu and then I'm going to equip
that there I don't know why everything
is oh great out like that the super
group but now I have a grappling hook on
the arm now let me see what that bad boy
looks like oh that's probably that I
don't know what that means or does but
that's there and that exists can I add
some coffee damn it milk thank you thank
you and then plenty of salt with which
to be able to make more water eventually
no not out work oh yeah you got to make
bleach that's right every guy's gonna
clean too many to make water then
oh you're almost making another water
let me pick and drink this and finally
my water solution is taken care of
so Jessica H you're gonna be the salt
lord see
oh no inactive inactive no Saints so
happy thank you that's a nice of you
I'll take that
oh yeah you're gonna give me one huh
where's my money where's my money
where's my water where's my water
where's my water where's my water
where the [ __ ] my water okay so now
that I got that I've got to water on
full on food I'm doing okay on health
it'll come back eventually and now I've
got mr. Fisher with the proper fish the
ultimate fish doing I don't know how
that's gonna work here uh all right well
I'll just drop down to the bottom yet
save here we go first test shot boom oh
that was a bit underwhelming at first
that actually turned out pretty cool
missa I was I was not anticipating a lot
out of that one but hey you turned it
around for me buddy you turned it around
so if I just
I can ah that's so cool I can swing
myself
whoa lagging got delete that file again
but if I get good at this like
eventually I literally I legitimately
could get good at this and start
flinging myself every whichaway Hey oh
[ __ ] yeah brah oh [ __ ] yeah brah well
that's why I let's go please I don't
know what the max range is I guess I
guess I just figured it out oh that's so
cool hey pull me pull me up I'm stuck oh
[ __ ] stuck nothing Oh goddamn [ __ ] all
this sure come on it whoo that's a
work-free hey buddy
hey buddy don't mind me buddy I'm just
gonna way walking okay we're controlled
we're controlled everything is fine you
whoop you whoop oh that's so much better
if it wasn't lagging so much good god
alright but I'm gonna make my way you
probably have guessed what I'm doing I'm
going down to that Lost River because I
want to see for myself all of the
changes that have been made down there
and I know there have been a lot that's
the noise I've never heard before
yeesh what the [ __ ] is in okay know what
that is bad judging by the fact that
everything in this hellhole is bad to me
ha [ __ ] goddamn it why are you doing
that you [ __ ] [ __ ] you and your
[ __ ] [ __ ] warping [ __ ] God
that gave me a legitimate spook oh [ __ ]
off with you I will grind your bones
into dust [ __ ] [ __ ] stop stop doing
that Robert ah not that don't do that it
hurts oh don't go in the inventory don't
go on inventory let go oh [ __ ] hell
don't go to the upgrade get in the sing
go try to find the Lost River just go
for it to [ __ ] go go away from the
[ __ ] war / piece of [ __ ] I know I'm
diseased you know not to embarrass me
about it now what I wanted not what I
wanted okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay we are very down now oh we're there
I found it okay I hate it I hate it
Oh Viking I can go down there totally
fine don't want to yet yeah let me back
let me make good everybody good
geez don't let go don't let go I've got
ready why is it so laggy god dammit okay
I wanted to say before I go down there
that's what I wanted I'm not I'm not
that much of a big bubble blowing baby
here we go oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh that is so cool these are legitimate
things in the ocean underwater rivers
and underwater Lakes there's things like
a brine basin which I think that's what
it's called it's just like a bowl of
like heavily salted water oh [ __ ]
alright hang on I'm gonna be right back
I have to get rid of this this lag real
quick
phoo well what the whoa oh my god why
the [ __ ] is that happening I was [ __ ]
it whoa that would have been terrible
that would have been terrible okay let's
just calm down for a second
so that's toxic to humans okay I don't
even have a health care I didn't think I
need it in my goddamn suit
let me just hop out real quick and then
put myself back in just to make sure it
recognizes that I'm definitely not in
the poisonous gas
jeezum cuz I was walking in there before
I just load it back in and all the
sudden I was out of my suit yeesh yeesh
yeesh okay but I don't either whatever
it's fine it's fine it's fine
everything's Fred let's continue on and
let's navigate
oh come on be a bit more spider-man than
that Ruby whoops this is why this is why
spider-man flying around the city didn't
make any sense how could he ever make it
anywhere oh that's so awesome anyway
yeah the the file that you have to
delete to get rid of a little bit of
alleges 14-15 that the 14-18 - 15-pin
what though
Oh that'd kill you oh that is here with
the music you care we what the [ __ ] oh
my god that is so cool I'm scary oh that
is awesome oh man I the last time I saw
this this whole area wasn't even done
yet that is wicked oh that's wicked all
the [ __ ] brine waterfall what the
[ __ ] are you
I've never seen you before look at me
look me I will grind the [ __ ] out of you
yeesh that's uh back look at that [ __ ] I
mean you can't look at anything else is
huge
oh my god it's ribs are tiny oh the way
[ __ ] okay that might have killed me
easily I got to be more careful than
that when I'm down here at the bottom of
the [ __ ] Lost River holy [ __ ] that is
awesome the brine waterfalls
that's super [ __ ] cool I'm assuming
that's what that is
[ __ ] that that's certainly that's not
offer oh I need sulfur I need sulfur to
get the jet up girl that looks like an
almost unnatural formation like someone
built that [ __ ] so this isn't a brine
River this is a sulfur which explains
why it's toxic to me but oh like that Oh
mark II know like Oh Mark II know like
wow okay rude much he I don't like it
and now I'm what were you what the [ __ ]
is that
where's that a bone fish what is what
are you I've never seen anything in here
but this is pretty much this is
supposedly this is supposedly where the
ghost Leviathan is going to be in this
haunted disturbing place and some weird
whoa
you don't look at me I will grind you to
a pulp [ __ ] oh that's so awesome
oh this is so cool oh hey buddy don't
you [ __ ] with me I [ __ ] with you okay
you got scared of me Hey oh [ __ ] I will
grind you up don't even try don't even
try yeah that's right run away you
little [ __ ] baby oh boy
how Boyan oh my god is so cool oh oh
there's a lot to explore down here - I
don't have a lot of time and I got to be
a bit better about mobility was swings
wrong good thing these are here for me
swinging long and shoot
okay alright alright then that's so
[ __ ] what oh don't if you want to
[ __ ] with me up [ __ ] up I will [ __ ] you
up I will [ __ ] you up
I will [ __ ] you up I can repair my [ __ ]
you know that sorry there was a cat yeah
oh man this oh that takes a lot more to
repair and that guy must be really tough
he did that much damage and take this
month to fix whoa are those I don't see
those are the those are the mind control
ones aren't they I should not go to
those oh I should not I definitely
should not and I should start to move
quicker because I'm gonna run out of a
run out of nutrients at some juncture
where Oh lag please carry me carry carry
me please carry my body carry my body
over the threshold of death [ __ ]
I could also double check to make sure
that this is court
it looks like courts but maybe down here
it's a little different that's quartz as
magnetite aluminum oxide crystal
whatever okay one of those I already
have a bunch but why not that's for a
souvenir
oh it's so cool I mean this is half of
what makes subnautica so amazing it's
just like they keep building it out and
you think that yo yeah oops sorry fish
do you think that oh yeah game world oh
whatever it's just kind of like Mia
whatever you know like every time they
make something is just so cool just
plain old you look at and you marvel and
go like oh my god I can't believe that
exists even though obviously don't
[ __ ] exist oh sorry
scared make learn make gonna try to see
what's up here mister who don't I want
to take a look at what these fish are I
know there's some sort of hoop fish
look that's [ __ ] whoa [ __ ] I will
grind you he's dumb [ __ ] I good God
ah all right so now that that moment
ended I think this probably just leads
out of the Lost River because it seems
to be a river just flowing downwards but
I've never seen this type of like this
type of fauna before or flora must be
some other entrance into the Lost River
that might dump out at a different point
I don't know how far I want to follow it
though
mama bomba mama Jamba bomba keep
forgetting our revolution oh oh that's
awesome
so that connects there vaguely remember
that I vaguely remember taking a route
in from one of those places but that
it's just so frickin cool it's so
unbelievably cool I know I've said it's
cool like a million times but still I
that's what I feel inside my heart about
this current occasion situation and even
though I'm almost nearly dead that don't
matter and won't stop me from saying
[ __ ] cool whee hey buddy sorry about
grinding you I mean I didn't really
grind you but you know can't help it on
the dance floor just got a grind
okay back into the river oh boy oh boy
man so it doesn't seem like there's a
lot here but even so it's just super
awesome god it's so cool just what they
have what they've built here just for
the sake of being here right now even if
they don't have a lot to do with it just
yet it's freaking amazing
and I'm actually oh there is actually
I'd like to see some extra stuff over
there I'm gonna take a gander take a
good old gander whoo whoo whoo okay
bigger than I thought oh no oh no
there's more ah oh it just keeps going
down it
oh it just keeps going oh that was just
the mouth of the river I thought I was
nearly done holy [ __ ] oh no oh no oh no
[Music]
what is that Oh what is that what is
that do I want to know what that is what
is that what is those is that still
quartz I haven't been able to find any
more so far I need that to be able to
make things and stuff what is that yeah
yeah yeah yeah Jay
oh yeah yeah yeah what is bad what are
that oh I can't go much deeper I can't
do it hey don't [ __ ] with me I don't
think I can go down there I think that's
too deep yeah that oh that's definitely
too deep yeah yep I can't make a dumber
you get back up
I got please back up back up okay so
this is the limit that I can go to right
now there's an there's an even there's
an even deeper level and I don't know
what the [ __ ] that is or why the [ __ ]
that's down here but that is frickin
amazing
I got to get back up anyway I'm gonna
run out of food and water but I got
plenty of stuff to get back but that's
going to be the end of this episode here
there is so much more to explore there's
so much more to explore I just need to
be able to make the additional pressure
compensators to be able to get down
there that looks like a way up I don't
know if I want to go that way or the way
I came
yeah I don't know but I'll figure that
out in the next episode I'm going to
leave this right here and then I'm going
to come back right down here so that you
guys don't miss a second of me drowning
like an idiot but I don't think it's
gonna happen
think I'm gonna make it gonna be cool so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know we thought down to comment
below now as always though see you in
the next week
[Music]
I
[Music]
[Music]